all right now think back and I already
mentioned it about you know 10 minutes
ago you can have a look at your own
notes from yesterday if you like what's
the thing I do next to start the ball
rolling to find out what kind of station
your point is is there a number where to
draw something remember say again ever
I needed are a table of values for the
derivative right so I need a dy on DX
table of values at the moment this is
our only tool for determining what kind
of stationary point it is so here's one
I prepared earlier
okay so so are you asking at this point
can I not just graph it and then off I
go yep okay so the short answer is yes
you could graph it however part of
reason why you can just graph this
question is I've given you a nice neat
easy thing you know I know exactly what
that looks like right I'm only doing
that for the purpose of illustration so
you don't get caught up in a complicated
example the real reason we asked you to
do this is because we give you functions
where you can't just graph it in fact
doing this process is a stepping stone
to be able to graph it right so yeah for
that reason I'm going to go into this
next half and do it in in sort of
algebraic terms so I was just kind of
killing time so you can draw your own
table values here right now if you
recall you know where you're stationary
point is and what you want to do is just
test a little bit to the left and a
little bit to the right to see what the
derivative is doing are you going from
increasing to decreasing are you going
from decreasing to increasing or any
other combination of those okay now you
need to select some values and you
generally try and pick ones that number
one a nearby and number two are
relatively easy to evaluate okay so I'm
just gonna pick one and three but
depending on the function you might need
to and we talked about this before you
might need to get closer you might need
to pick numbers like 1.9 and 2.1 okay
we'll go into more detail as you get
more complicated functions as to why you
would pick these values but for now I'm
pretty happy with the ones that we've
got so I'll give you a second now you
got this table of values and what we're
going to do is put one two and three if
I were donated to two we already have a
value for that we want to put one and
three into the derivative not the
original function
we're actually evaluating what's dy on
DX when X equal one what is it when x
equals zero have you already evaluated
okay so I think you put into y equals 2x
minus 4 right that's sorry dy/dx equals
2x minus 4 there's our derivative right
there
see that so when you substitute one into
there you get 2 minus 1 which is
negative 2 is that ok do we wrap and
when you put in positive 3 yes you do in
fact yet you get 6 minus 4 which is 2
okay now you may find it helpful
underneath where you've done this to
sort of write down for yourself oh
that's a decreasing function and then
it's horizontal and then it's increasing
so even that tells you what kind of
stationary point it is ok so I was just
highlighting there that when you are we
call this by the way I might even write
this for you and we call this thing not
just a um a table values we also
sometimes call it a neighborhood tests
which is a very cute name right it is to
say we want to look in the nearby area
around this stationary point now the
word nearby or neighborhood it's
relative yeah it's like is is one unit
away right is one unit away from the
stationary point is that close or is it
far and it kind of depends on the
function if I gave you remember this
function I gave you up here this this
guy over here imagine if I gave you one
that it still look like that but was
squashed like so right if you go one
unit you might be actually really far
away from your stationary point in which
case you need to come in closer so
instead of picking one and three you
might pick one point nine and two point
one they may be you know close enough
you may even have to go further than
that one point nine nine 2.01
the whole idea is that nearby is
relative okay those are just examples
all right so
whoopsie-daisy I arrays most of my table
which I didn't mean to so I've got here
now enough information to describe
what's going on
okay what I'm looking for is what is the
change in sign right what is the change
in sign for this one it's gone from what
to what negative to positive right
negative to positive so this is negative
whoops I write it in their own color
negative to positive like so okay now
you can already see from that little
kind of series of lines that I drew
underneath our table values you can
already see that is a minimum turning
point I'm gonna write that down the
bottom minimum turning point but of
course this is not the only thing that
might actually happen we might actually
have the change in sign in reverse
direction yeah so if I went from
positive to negative what would that
tell us it's going up it's flat it's
going down what's that that's a maximum
thank you d maximum okay now there's one
last possibility right
it might not change time it might not
change sign might go positive positive
or it might go negative negative okay
what do we call that by the way when
there's a consistent sign from on the
left and the right one we call that I
gave it a name in that big Venn diagram
a horizontal point of inflection that's
a bit of a mouthful isn't it okay so
these are our these are three
alternatives okay it's a minimum or it's
a maximum or it's a horizontal point of
inflection so you can see here I would
say I would conclude okay I've got that
two common negative one I already said
it's up it's actually here on the
left-hand side one of these because
that's actually what happened so serene
you're asking the question earlier like
how would I conclude this well now that
I'm completely done I'm gonna say right
down the bottom here therefore 2 comma
negative 1 is a minimum turning point
that's my conclusion though it's worth
mentioning that frequently my next thing
that I'll have to do is graph this so
now I will say oh I know what it looks
like I'm gonna go to a Cartesian plan
I'm gonna draw it accordingly okay